Speaker 1: Donald Trump has had a mental breakdown
over being called out accurately for the things he
said about the Constitution. Now, let's back
up just a moment to make sure we're all on
the same page. Reporting accurately described
Donald Trump's demands for a new, new election
or to be reinstated as president of the United
States. Based on the Hunter Biden Twitter files,
which were a complete and total flop. In
a post untruth social, which we looked at
yesterday. And I will show you again, Donald
Trump actually says, quote, A massive fraud,
a massive fraud of this type and magnitude
allows for the termination of all rules,
regulations and articles, even those found in
the Constitution. He said it. He clearly said
it. Trump was criticized for saying it because
it's dangerous and it's outrageous. And it's the
metaphorical defecation on the Constitution that
he was accurately described as partaking in. And
Trump flipped out yesterday. Untruth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth, central.
Speaker 1: Lying, trying to deny and of course,
typing in all capital letters. This is starting
to be Kanye West level stuff. Or maybe the Kanye
West stuff is actually Donald Trump level stuff.
I don't know. Take a look at this insane rant.
Trump says, quote, The fake news is actually
trying to convince the American people that I
said I wanted to terminate the Constitution.
This is simply more disinformation and lies, just
like Russia, Russia, Russia and all of their other
hoaxes and scams. What I said was that when there
is massive and widespread fraud and deception,
as has been irrefutably proven in the
2020 presidential election, by the way,
it hasn't. Steps must be immediately taken to
right the wrong. Only fools would disagree with
that and accept stolen elections. Maga. And then
we enter all caps. Insanity. Quote Simply put, if
an election is irrefutably fraudulent, it should
go to the rightful winner or at a minimum, be
redone where open and blatant fraud is involved.
There should be no time limit for change. Trump
continuing in all caps. We want people who, quote,
legitimately won the election. I don't know why
he puts legitimately in quotes. I don't know that
the quotes mean what he thinks they mean. We want
people who legitimately won the election to lead
our country, not people who had to cheat in order
to win that I agree with and we got that person.
Trump is like your conspiracy theorist uncle,
except instead of being some random
guy that you see twice a year,
it's the former president of the United States
who's putting this stuff out. And of course,
Trump did say the thing that now he says he
didn't say. He may not have said terminate
the Constitution, but he said terminate parts of
it when you want. The original post was, quote.
So with the big with the revelation of massive
and widespread fraud and deception, in working
closely with big tech companies, the DNC and the
Democrat Party. Do you throw the presidential
election results of 2020 out and declare the
rightful winner? Or do you have a new election?
A massive fraud of this type and magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules, regulations and
articles, even those found in the Constitution.
Our great quote Founders did not want and would
not condone false and fraudulent elections.
He said it. It was dangerous. It horrified the
world and even some Republicans. He was called
out. Now he's denying it because he's furious.
This is getting worse and worse and worse. And
many Republicans don't even believe that this
is disqualifying in terms of his chance or
possibility at once. Again, being president
of the United States. Will have the posts, the
clips and all of it on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show. Also, make sure
you're subscribed on our YouTube channel. We are
heading towards 2 million subscribers on YouTube.
That's YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.